hey guys welcome to the first ever
edition of my karate Mia recap now this
is where I explain anything to do with
the series in like one to two minutes I
plan to do these in addition to the
regular videos that I put out on
weekends so do let me know any
suggestions you have the future recaps
although I should let you know that I
have the next three already decided but
without further ado here I got gun
tamaki as multiple quirks explained so
to start with Canton machia has
heightened senses to a ridiculous degree
for those of you who've seen my Mike
with an academia review you'll know that
he was able to just take two snips of
the air and then locate Shigure aki who
was in a completely different city by
that point imagine all the different
smells that were in between him and
sugar Aki and yet he was still able to
pinpoint exactly where he was it doesn't
stop there however as macchia says
himself that he also has great ears so
much so that even when he's sleeping you
can't land a hit on the guy thomas would
not stand a chance as it says on this
panel his body grows in battle this
seems to be the effects of some kind of
gag anta fication quirk and it's kind of
noticeable when you compare how he
looked when he encountered Gran Torino
versus how he looked when he encountered
Kirishima so gigantic Asian during
battle would be his second quirk now his
third quirk is something that I would
personally call hardening not to imply
that in some way he's connected to
Kirishima or crimson riot but that's
kind of exactly what I'm saying his skin
is permanently hardened and that he
doesn't need to actually activate it in
the way that Kirishima does and it also
makes him fireproof it also goes without
saying that Gauguin Tamaki is so huge
that he probably wouldn't fit inside any
gym that exists on the earth so it's
safe to assume that his awesome power
and strength is the result of his quirk
at work we've seen him tear a hole in
the side of a mountain tear up a city
and even when he's not really trying he
can start to crush the building with his
bare hand and on top of that he has
incredible speed so much so that in this
panel the trees were literally ripped up
from around him his intense stamina
plays a part in this as he's able to
travel long distances in the flash
without needing any rest and can fight
for up to 48 hours non-stop and then
when you remember that he gets bigger as
he fights his quartz kind of fit
together perfectly
so just to recap he has overpowered
senses incredible speed incredible
strength his body grows in battle he has
godlike stamina and his skin is
fireproof and perm
be hardened and that my friends was
Oliver gotta Marcius quirks is what
noting that they don't have official
names so this video is based on what we
seen him actually do by my count he has
six distinctive powers that could be
classified as separate quirks
technically seven if you count the
infrared vision that he must have I mean
where are his pupils guys I can't see
him and I'm still genuinely wondering
how gran torino was able to get out of a
battle with this guy alive anyway hope
you enjoyed this first edition of my
hair academia recap the next one will
come out very soon and it will summarize
the entire cultural festival arc in
around two minutes so make sure you
stick around for that and subscribe as
we on that far of 40,000 subscribers
peace out
you